FEMALE SPEAKER: Today,
we are very lucky to have
with us chef Chris Ying.
Chris is the co-founder of
the James Beard Award-winning
magazine, "Lucky Peach."
In fact, a congratulations are
in order for the three awards
you just won this weekend.
CHRIS YING: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So the
magazine is an awesome food
and lifestyle journal that
has a very unique perspective
on food.
And actually, I just read
an article this morning
describing the
magazine as, quote,
"a food magazine for
people who wouldn't usually
pick up a food magazine."
And I thought that
was pretty fitting.
It's innovative in its
explorations of themes
through essays, art,
photography, and recipes--
often actually highlighting
some of the Bay Area's bests.
And it's definitely become
one of the most popular reads
among today's foodies.
Chris also designed an
edited several cookbooks
in collaboration with his
"Lucky Peach" co-founder.
And their latest book,
"The Wurst of Lucky Peach,"
is a look into the great
sausage trails of the world.
But Chris, I'll let you say
some more about the book.
First, I would like
you to please join me
in welcoming Chris to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YING: Thank you.
Thanks.
Thanks for having me, guys.
Thanks for putting
on this fake beach
volleyball game outside
to create the whole Google
vibe for my pleasure.
I really appreciate that.
I know doesn't usually happen.
No, seriously-- thank you
guys all so much for coming.
I have zero faith in my ability
to draw an audience, ever,
so the fact that anybody's
here is very special to me.
Let me also start
with a disclaimer.
I am not a chef, despite
that lovely introduction.
I have cooked in kitchens,
but I have to say,
given that this will be online,
no, no, "Chris-y" no "chef-y."
So, yeah.
One other little preamble--
there's beer over there.
This whole thing will be much
more enjoyable for all of us
if you guys drink beer.
I won't be offended if
you get up in the middle
to replenish your beers.
But otherwise, hi.
My name's Chris.
I'm the editor-in-chief
of "Lucky Peach."
Look, these guys are going
for a beer right now.
It's amazing.
You just say something,
and it happens.
This is our second cookbook
from "Lucky Peach."
Our first one was a book called
"101 Easy Asian Recipes,"
which was originally a joke.
We were going to make this
book called "101 Easy Asian
Recipes," and it was going to
be 101 super difficult recipes
that no one could pull off.
But somewhere along the
line, we grew up a little bit
and decided that helping people
cook at home was important,
and that kind of making
esoteric jokes that only
we thought were
funny was not really
that helpful to anybody else.
So this book is the
second one we've made,
and the first in a series
of single-subject cookbooks.
So I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the "Time Life"
cookbooks that were
sort of covered,
you know, a single cuisine
from around the world,
or a single ingredient.
Or the "River Cottage"
series-- or, like, Alice Waters
has done books about just
vegetables, or just fruits.
Those are sort of
spirit animals.
Those are what we love
and are inspired by.
But this book is nothing
like that whatsoever.
It is not comprehensive,
or exhaustive,
or nearly as intelligent as
those books are-- primarily
because I wrote most of it.
So it's just not that smart.
No, I keep on describing
this series of books
as a series of
books that you could
enjoy reading in the
bathroom and then
find useful in the kitchen.
One of the few items that you
could bring between those two
rooms safely.
So anyway, that is the book.
It's all about sausages.
And the reason why we decided
to make a book entirely
about sausages, to be
honest with you, mostly
has to do with the fact that the
title was really funny to us.
"The Wurst of Lucky Peach"
was sort of too good
of a pun to pass
up, so we decided
make this book about sausages.
And at first, when I sat down to
kind of put this book together,
I thought, wow, this is
way too narrow of a topic.
Like, not that many people
care that much about sausage.
Why are we doing a book
entirely about sausages?
Then I started
thinking more about it.
And it started to be like
when you learn a new word,
and all of a sudden,
everyone you know
has been using this
word for years,
and you just have not understood
what they were saying.
And it was like
that with sausages,
where all of a sudden,
everywhere I would go, I'd be,
like, oh, man, we
eat a lot of sausage.
Like, we really like
sausages in this country
and around the world.
And I started thinking
more and more about sausage
not as this joke thing, or not
as this kind of niche food,
but more as an important part
of our culinary cultures.
And that goes sort
around the world.
Anywhere that you've had people
who eat meat, and have had
to worry about where food is
going to come from tomorrow,
or the next day-- or what
to do with this animal
that they just slaughtered,
and have all this extra meat--
or anywhere there's been a
lower socioeconomic class that
hasn't had access
to sort of the,
you know, filet
mignon and tenderloin,
and has had to make do with
off-cuts and intestines
and things like that-- anywhere
that's happened in the world,
sausage has been invented.
And that's what sausage is for.
Sausage is for making
food out of stuff
that you don't necessarily
want to eat by itself, for lack
of a better description.
Wow, you'd think I
would have a better
way of talking about
sausages, given
that I wrote a book about it.
No, but it's
evolved beyond that,
to a point where I think
that sausage represents
kind of everything good
about meat cookery,
engineered to be easier.
So what are the hard
things about cooking meat?
You have to cook things to a
certain temperature for them
to still be good.
They have to be cooked to medium
rare for a steak to be good.
Once you kind of go over
medium into well done,
you kind of have this
tough piece of meat
that's not as good
as you want it to be.
Getting flavor into a steak,
or a piece of chicken breast,
or pork is a huge challenge.
You marinate things, or
you brine things in order
to make them flavorful.
And then you've got
a whole industry
of these sort of
prime cut meats,
like wagyu or Kobe
beef, that are prized
for, like, the marbling of
the fat, and how much fat
they have in them.
Well, then, you've
got sausage, which
you can cook to well done.
You can season however
you want, and put as much
seasoning as you want in it, and
it will be seasoned throughout.
And you can put as much fucking
fat in there as you see fit.
So, honestly, like,
sausage has come
from this really humble
beginning to this thing
where, done right, you
can make it the highest
form of meat cookery.
So, anyway.
The book is also funny.
There's lots of poop
jokes and stuff.
I highly recommend it for
Mother's Day or something.
Yeah.
So today, we're going
to make some sausage.
How many people have made
sausage at home before?
All right.
Three to four people.
There's sort of a whole
spectrum of difficulty
when it comes to making sausage.
You can make really
difficult sausage--
you can make mortadella, which
has to be sort of emulsified
at a certain temperature.
And you have to stud it with
pistachios and peppercorns.
And it can be pretty difficult.
And on the other
end of the spectrum,
you can make sausage
really easily.
And that's what we're
going to do today,
because I'm not risking
anything difficult.
So this is one of the things
I discovered when I started
thinking about sausage, and
what to include in this book,
was, like, oh, sausage is
niche, sausage is, too narrow,
there's not that much sausage.
And then I was, like, wait, I
eat sausage four times a week
in the form of chorizo.
If you live in the Bay Area,
in California in general,
you've eaten chorizo.
So chorizo is, you know,
probably the best known
Mexican sausage.
And so, here to help
me make this today
is a Googler who
submitted a special video
to win the dubious
honor of helping me.
Will you guys welcome Brandon?
[APPLAUSE]
And also, from my
"Lucky Peach" staff,
this is Aralyn, who's going
to say smart things while I'm
distracted cooking.
Hi, Aralyn.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Hello.
CHRIS YING: Welcome, Aralyn.
How's it going, man?
You're among the people who
have made sausage before.
BRANDON CHALK: I am.
CHRIS YING: OK.
BRANDON CHALK: Not
chorizo, though.
CHRIS YING: Not chorizo.
BRANDON CHALK: But I think that
was my first recipe in the book
that I wanted to make.
CHRIS YING: All right.
We're going to do it right here.
Chorizo starts here.
You know, a lot of people
are kind of turned off
by the idea of making
sausage, because there's
all this equipment involved.
You've got to buy a
grinder, and a stuffer,
and all this kind of stuff.
But there's also just
loose, uncased sausage
which most choirzo, when you
buy it from a Mexican grocery--
it comes in a big bulk, then
you buy it by the pound.
And today, we're going to
do it without a grinder.
We're going to do it with
a Cuisinart food processor.
I'm not shilling you
Cuisinart specifically.
[GRINDING]
There it goes.
BRANDON CHALK: It works.
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
Let's get started, right?
So the backbone of
chorizo is chilies.
And in this case--
this recipe comes
from Rick Bayliss, the wonderful
Mexican chef in Chicago.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
CHRIS YING: For
Chicago or something.
The chile we're going
to be using today
is an ancho chile, which
is a dried poblano?
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Couldn't--
CHRIS YING: Yeah, yeah.
A dried poblano.
So, what we're-- nice, nice.
[LAUGHTER]
So we've got some
soaking right here.
You can see this, right?
There's no way to
see thi-- whatever.
BRANDON CHALK: Yeah, there is.
CHRIS YING: OK, there it is.
What we did with these
before was, you stem them.
So they come dried like this.
You'll stem them by just tearing
off the stem with your hands,
and then dump out
these seeds, like so.
And you'll kind of just,
like, tear it open.
Want to do this?
BRANDON CHALK: Sure.
CHRIS YING: You'll just
tear it open and seed it.
And then you'll toast
them on a hot saute pan--
[WHISTLING]
--oops, sorry.
Sorry.
What kind of sausages
have you made in the past?
BRANDON CHALK: I've done
some with caul fat, which
is another really
easy way to make them.
And then we did a bunch
of Italian sausages
at my friend's place.
Because he has one of the super
crazy sausage stuffers that you
can fit, like--
CHRIS YING: Oh, yeah.
We're not going to do that.
BRANDON CHALK: No.
CHRIS YING: So just
put that in there
and then press it on there.
You can use a spatula,
if you're scared, or not.
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
Would you like one?
CHRIS YING: It really takes,
like, ten seconds on each--
BRANDON CHALK: We have
good worker's comp here.
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
So you'll just press
this on the pan
for 10 seconds on each side.
You'll see it starts to kind
of blister a little bit,
as his fingertips
are currently doing.
And it'll start to
smell incredible--
just, like, toasty and fruity.
You can flip it over.
This is just kind
of to-- I'm going
to make this up-- this is
to "activate" the flavors.
It doesn't do that.
It doesn't do that at all.
And so, you'll just do this
with each of these chilies.
This recipe, I think, calls for
something like 12 ancho chiles.
Yeah, whatever.
It doesn't matter.
This is just for show.
[LAUGHTER]
You'll soak them in
water for 20 minutes.
You take a plate, and
you can push it on top
and submerge them, so they
stay under and get soft.
And then we're
going to pulse them.
I got you.
BRANDON CHALK:
Child safety lock.
Thank you.
CHRIS YING: So just chilies
in there, without the water.
Everybody's had chorizo, right?
So you're pretty aware
of the flavor profile.
It's really, you know, a
little spicy, a little acidic,
a little sour.
That's kind of a
hallmark of-- hold
on one second-- of sausages
in other places as well.
So in Southeast Asia, they'll
hang chiles to dry and ferment
a little bit, so they get this
kind of sour taste to them.
Chorizo has this
little sourness to it.
It's not something
that we usually
have in our sort of
American-style sausages.
But in the process
of making this book,
it's been something I've
really enjoyed tasting.
Right?
So, here's what you're
going to do next.
Bay leaves into the
mortar and pestle.
BRANDON CHALK: Yup.
CHRIS YING: Throw these--
throw that in there, too.
BRANDON CHALK: Smells fresh.
CHRIS YING: Add thyme, marjoram.
And just powderize that.
BRANDON CHALK: So do you
have any favorite places
for chorizo?
CHRIS YING: Do I have
favorite places for chorizo?
BRANDON CHALK: Or is
that a loaded question?
CHRIS YING: I'm going
to help you out here
with a little bit of salt.
So I spend a lot of time
in the Mission District
in San Francisco,
so the chorizo I eat usually
comes in very late night
burrito form.
But other than
that, I really like
this thing called
a pombazo, which
is like a torta filled with
potatoes and chorizo and crema,
and then they dunk the whole
thing into this red guajillo
chili sauce.
And then they'll
griddle it crispy.
It's pretty delicious.
You're not having
too much luck here.
Let me help you out a little it.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: And
where do you get that?
CHRIS YING: You can get that
at a place called La Torta
Gorda, which is on 24th Street.
I'm not having any
more luck, either.
We're going to
pretend that worked.
So basically, herbs, oregano,
cinnamon, more oregano,
for some reason.
A little bit of ground
clove, salt, cider vinegar.
And I imagine this is going
to need a little bit of water
to get it going.
AUDIENCE: Chris, why is
it important to pestle
before you put it in?
CHRIS YING: Ideally, I wanted
to break down the bay leaves,
so it was powdered,
and it didn't get-- you
didn't have big chunks of it.
But we failed.
In life, sometimes,
you just gotta,
like, accept your
failures and move on.
You can't-- go for it, man.
BRANDON CHALK: Pulse, or--
CHRIS YING: Yeah,
pulse it a little bit.
[PULSING]
Nah, just go for it.
[GRINDING]
So what we're making is
this kind of spice puree
that will basically
just fold in with pork.
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
Want me to get it?
CHRIS YING: Will
you grab that fork?
So once this is smooth--
that seem smooth to you?
BRANDON CHALK: Yeah.
CHRIS YING: All right.
I hope it's smooth, because
your next job is going
to depend on it being smooth.
We're going to push--
BRANDON CHALK: That
looks pretty good.
CHRIS YING: Ooh.
This is my least
favorite part, and this
is why it's helpful
to have a helper here.
BRANDON CHALK: An
unassuming helper.
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Chris, do you
prefer green or red chorizo?
CHRIS YING: Oh, that's
a great question.
We're actually making
two chorizos today.
We're making a red and
a green, which I think
is maybe less familiar
to most people.
And the green is green
from fresh herbs,
and chiles, and
tomatillos, and spinach.
And I hadn't really
ever seen it until we
started working on this book.
And I still prefer
the original "rojo"--
[LAUGHING]
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
Not the "verde?"
CHRIS YING: But I also like the
"verde" for different purposes,
like green eggs and ham.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Oh, yeah.
And at our favorite place north
of the city, at El Molino,
Karen Taylor uses
green chorizo a lot.
CHRIS YING: Oh, yeah.
Have you guys ever been to
El Molino Central on Sonoma.
BRANDON CHALK: It's awesome.
CHRIS YING: Have you ever seen
this brand called Primavera?
They make tortillas,
and chips, and salsa.
You'll have them at Whole
Foods, and they have, like,
a stand at the Ferry
building on Saturdays.
Anyways, this woman, Karen
Taylor, runs this company.
And she has a restaurant
in Sonoma called El Molino
Central, where I'll be going
after this demonstration
for Cinco de Mayo.
And it's legit, like, best
Mexican food in California,
I feel like.
Just throwing it out there.
Throwing it out there.
BRANDON CHALK: You didn't
even mention the patio.
That's, like, one of
the best things there.
CHRIS YING: Oh, beautiful patio.
I'll see you guys later.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so keep going.
Why don't you scrape off here?
And so, for the
purposes of this,
we're going to pretend that
you finished doing this,
and we're going to move on here.
BRANDON CHALK: Perfect.
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
Here, I can take that.
CHRIS YING: So, basically, you
just want to get out, like,
the big chunks of nonsense.
Give me the-- let
me just hold this.
You want to get rid of the
stringy bits of the bay leaf
that are stuck on there, any
unprocessed chunks of chile,
and things like that.
And then you're going to have
this relatively smooth puree.
So this is the part that I
feel like is pretty neat.
You don't need the
KitchenAid attachment.
You don't need a meat grinder,
or anything like that.
You can really make an
[INAUDIBLE] sausage out
of your food processor.
So pork shoulder, which you
can supplement with fat back.
If you go to your
butcher and you ask them,
they're never going to
have it out for you to buy.
But sausage--
generally, you know,
you want this percentage between
30% fat and 70% lean meat.
So if your pork
shoulder's not that fat,
you can ask them for fat
back, and they'll usually
have some in the back.
Just the other day, I bought
some, and I took it home,
and it was rotten.
So check your fat back
before you get home.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Lesson of the day.
CHRIS YING: Such an unhelpful
lesson to anybody at all.
Freezing the meat
really helps when you're
doing it in a food processor.
It keeps it from kind of
getting, like, squishing
instead of slicing.
You'll be able to kind
of mince the meat more.
You kind of want
this coarse texture
to it, which is actually
the benefit of doing it
in a proper grinder-- you're
going to get an even grind,
an even coarseness,
according to what you want.
When you do it here,
the other day, I
had huge cubes of fat
left in my sausage,
and other parts were
kind of just pureed.
But, that's fine, because I'm
telling you do it this way.
BRANDON CHALK: And how long
should you generally freeze it?
CHRIS YING: You do want
to freeze it just until it
gets kind of crisp edges.
BRANDON CHALK: OK.
CHRIS YING: So not so it's hard,
but just so it's not squishy,
like my body.
[PULSING]
And so here's a
pulsing situation.
[PULSING]
You don't want to get into the
food bolus situation, where
you've just got this
big ball spinning around
in your food processor.
And doing in batches also helps.
So you're just trying to get
a pretty coarse grind on it.
That looks pretty good, right?
I don't know.
BRANDON CHALK: Yeah.
I think it works.
CHRIS YING: And here-- why
don't you do the next batch.
And this is basically it.
You pulse the meat until
it looks like sausage.
Every knows what
sausage looks like.
Just do it until it
looks like sausage.
And then mix it
with your spice mix.
Cover it, refrigerate it.
Let it kind of absorb all
that flavor overnight.
And then literally, that's it.
Then you have chorizo.
[PULSING]
Yeah, dude.
Yeah, let's call it.
Beautiful.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Ew. [LAUGHING]
CHRIS YING: It's not the most
glamorous of cooking processes,
but, you know-- works.
That's whatever.
Let's just not even
do the rest of it.
BRANDON CHALK: Perfect.
CHRIS YING: Why don't you
mix these together by hand?
[LAUGHTER]
BRANDON CHALK: Thank you, Chris.
CHRIS YING: I love so much
that you volunteered for this.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Here.
CHRIS YING: OK.
Meanwhile, let me get
the-- you stay here.
Do we have the other pork?
OK.
Are you not done yet?
BRANDON CHALK: Uh, it's done.
CHRIS YING: All right.
So this is it.
I mean, the rest of
the pork would kind of
make the proportions right,
but this is-- where am I going?
Here.
[LAUGHTER]
This is it.
This is chorizo.
Now you can fry it with
eggs, with potatoes,
whatever-- however you
want to eat chorizo.
You've made your own.
You can buy quality
meat and be sort of
certain of the provenance
of where you got this.
It's not from a shady place.
That's chorizo.
This is red chorizo.
Now, let's make the green.
The green is even easier,
because the meat's
already ground.
Look at that.
Perfect.
So we take a chile.
And have you guys ever
charred chillies on the stove?
Most people have
done this, right?
You just-- this thing work?
BRANDON CHALK: Yup.
It's on.
CHRIS YING: All right.
Like, that's it.
Stick it on there.
You wait until it's burnt,
until it's blackened.
You turn it, you
blacken it all over.
And basically, you get this.
You let it kind of
cool down enough
so that you can handle it.
And then all this skin is
just going to peel off really
easily.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Why don't
you want the skin in there?
CHRIS YING: Because it's
all papery and terrible.
That's a good question, though.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Thanks, Chris.
CHRIS YING: This is how
culinary-- next year, Grant
Achatz is going to serving,
like, poblano chile skin,
and I'm going to be over here
being, like, I was an idiot.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: I mean,
they might make great chips.
I don't know.
BRANDON CHALK: So do
you pair different beers
with your green and red chorizo?
Or do you stick
to the same beer?
CHRIS YING: Uh,
I am a person who
likes flavorless beer
in all situations.
So I don't really give too
much thought to pairing it.
But do you have beers you prefer
with one versus the other?
BRANDON CHALK: Well, actually,
you know, I'm visiting,
so I have a great--
CHRIS YING: Holy shit.
BRANDON CHALK: --great corner
store right next to my hotel.
So I brought some choice--
[LAUGHTER]
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Some classic--
CHRIS YING: I feel
like I'm getting iced.
Is this what it's like
when you get iced?
BRANDON CHALK: No.
That would be very rude to
do to a guest at Google.
CHRIS YING: Um, yeah.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: But these are
some of your favorite beers.
CHRIS YING: Wonderful.
So this is for-- the traditional
Tecate is for the red chorizo.
And the Dos Equis
is for the verde.
BRANDON CHALK: Perfect.
CHRIS YING: Beautiful.
OK.
So you char chile.
All right-- should
we drink these beers?
Is that what you want?
There we go.
[LAUGHTER]
Cheers.
Ah.
BRANDON CHALK:
[INAUDIBLE] was legal.
It's all good.
CHRIS YING: Ah.
Wonderful.
OK.
What were we doing?
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Green chorizo.
BRANDON CHALK: You're
making sausages.
CHRIS YING: So you char chile.
You peel the skin off
into the processor.
Take a whole bunch of cilantro.
Break off just the
very end of it.
I'm not kidding.
This is Rick Bayliss'
method, not mine.
Don't blame me.
Serrano chilies-- you can
always go less if you want.
But basically, just take off
the stems, and then into-- guys,
we gotta sharpen our knives
here-- into the processor.
Have at it, dude.
[PULSING]
BRANDON CHALK: So in the
creation of the book,
you guys travel to a
lot of different places.
Do you have any memorable
stories about eating sausages?
CHRIS YING: Memorable
sausage eating stories--
there are two travel
logs in that book,
in fact, that I
wrote specifically
about eating sausages,
both in Southeast Asia
and in Mitteleuropa, by which I
mean Germany, Austria, France.
What just happened?
BRANDON CHALK: I think I did it.
CHRIS YING: Keep going.
No-- what's
interesting is that we
eat so much sausage
in the States,
but there's not a culture
around eating sausages
in the way there is sort of
in beer halls in Germany,
or, you know, in Alsace
region of France,
where it's such a
part of what you do.
You go specifically out
to eat choucroute garnie.
You go to a beer hall.
You have sausages and beer.
And we love that-- I mean,
we've got restaurants
built around that idea.
But it's not something we do.
So
So there were a lot of kind
of really memorable moments
for me.
There was a-- oh, that's good.
We were in this little
town called Miesbach,
which is known for Weisswurst
which is a white sausage,
like an emulsified sausage.
And one of our interns put
together kind of a guide
for me.
Put that in here.
And he was like,
when you get there,
make sure you eat Weisswurst.
And the way you do it
is, you pop off one end,
as though it's a
cigar, and then you
zuzel the sausage, which means
you put it in your mouth,
and you suck the meat
out of the casing.
And we were sitting
here in this restaurant,
being like, this fucking
intern is just, like,
having a laugh at our expense.
He wants us all-- like,
these dumb Americans
to be sitting in this tiny
town, sucking sausage meat out
of this thing.
And I look over,
and this old dude,
like, drinking a beer at 9
am, was zuzeling his sausage.
And I was like, holy
shit, this is amazing.
So anyway, that's
one interesting st--
AUDIENCE: Did you do it?
CHRIS YING: I did it.
It's like-- I feel like I burst
a vein in my temple trying
to suck the meat out.
And it was just not pretty.
All right.
So this sausage-- the green
chorizo's even easier.
Like you saw, this
is spinach powder,
which is basically dehydrated,
powderized spinach.
You can buy this on Amazon,
or-- that's OK for you guys
to buy things on Amazon, right?
Even though we're at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
Google Shopping,
or whatever it is.
And herbs, chiles, and
then pre-ground pork.
Ready to get dirty again?
BRANDON CHALK: I am.
CHRIS YING: And that's
it-- that's green chorizo.
You just mix it in there.
Let it sit overnight.
And that's the
whole entire thing.
You've got this really
brilliant green sausage.
BRANDON CHALK: So speaking of
zuzeling and getting dirty--
CHRIS YING: Yeah, yeah.
All right, here we go.
BRANDON CHALK: You
must have plenty
of good sausage innuendos.
CHRIS YING: Oh, yeah.
This book is full of
sausage innuendos.
I mean, it was just like--
BRANDON CHALK: So
I think we have
a pretty raunchy crowd that
might want to hear one or two.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS YING: The thing is,
there's no subtle joke
to make about sau-- like,
sausage looks like a penis.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, that's about it.
Goes into a bun, which
looks like a butt--
I don't know-- there's nothing
subtle about sausage humor.
Aralyn is the new, young
face of "Lucky Peach"--
the modern, enlightened woman.
And I'm just like the caveman
vestige, where I'm just like,
ha ha, penises are so funny.
So the book-- our
publisher's really sweet,
and didn't ask us to pull back
at all on the dick and poop
humor.
Oh, it also looks like poo.
[LAUGHTER]
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
In all varieties.
CHRIS YING: All varieties.
But my own staff
was like, I think
we need ease up with the
dick and poop jokes, dude.
There it is!
You made sausage!
You made two kinds of sausage.
BRANDON CHALK: I have.
In what-- 15 minutes?
CHRIS YING: In 15 minutes.
BRANDON CHALK: I'm quitting.
CHRIS YING: So that's it.
That's the green chorizo.
What do we do?
Hold it up to this one again?
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Put it
in front of your face.
CHRIS YING: It looks so good.
Yeah, so that's it.
So the book has recipes for
really easy sausages like this.
It has recipes for
cased sausages.
And then a whole slew of
things to do with hot dogs
and sausages, as well
as, like, there's
a great recipe for
pancakes in there,
because pigs in a
blanket, you know.
Like, you need a good,
solid pancake recipe.
Hot dog chili.
But yeah, I really hope
people will read this book
and appreciate the kind of
dorky sense of wonderment
we have about sausage
and about exploring how
it's eaten around the world.
What else did I miss, Aralyn?
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
There's some rants
throughout the
book, where you will
learn how you should
and should not eat
sausage-- or hot dogs, really.
BRANDON CHALK: Ketchup.
CHRIS YING: I got a
real problem with--
BRANDON CHALK: Should I bring
my fancy ketchup out right now?
CHRIS YING: Oh my god.
What is in that bag you
have over there, dude?
[LAUGHTER]
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Maybe
it'll convert you.
Maybe you should try it.
CHRIS YING: Do you have
some kind of fancy ketchup?
BRANDON CHALK: No.
I hate fancy ketchup, too.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: I thought
you were being serious.
CHRIS YING: I appreciate it.
There's a thing in the
book about-- everyone
wants me to bring this up,
but I hate homemade ketchup.
I find, when you go to a
restaurant, and they're like,
served with our house-made curry
ketchup, I just want to leave.
I don't find any
ketchup ever made
to be better than Heinz ketchup.
And if I want curry powder all
over my ketchup-- oh my God,
sorry-- I'll do it myself.
So anyway, you'll find all that
kind of good stuff in the book.
You guys have questions?
Nobody ever wants
to ask questions,
but-- oh my god,
I was just going
to say, wait, I have
like a whole thing
to encourage you
to ask questions.
If you ask a question,
I'll give you
one of these cool
bonus fun books
we made to go with "The
Wurst of Lucky Peach."
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Wow.
Wow.
CHRIS YING: There's
only two of them.
And there's also all these
stickers, which you can get,
too.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: Great
car bumper stickers.
AUDIENCE: So I love
chorizo, but it's always
so greasy and oily
when it's served.
Why is that?
Is it just-- they don't
drain it out of the pan
when you're cooking?
CHRIS YING: Yeah, I mean,
chorizo's one of these things
that-- it's just a high
fat percentage sausage.
You know, they'll
cook it often times,
like when it's cooked at
a tacqueria or something--
it's on a big flat top,
and so a lot of that fat
is going to drain out.
But one of the benefits
of making your own
is you kind of control how much
fat you have in your chorizo.
So I bought the kind of super,
super cheap, shitty brands
of chorizo with a little
pig, like, eating himself
on the label, or whatever.
And it comes in a plastic tube.
And you put it in the pan,
and it just melts into liquid.
I know what you're
talking about.
It's really fatty.
But, again, this one--
it's just pork shoulder,
so it's as much fat as
there is in pork shoulder.
So, yeah.
Go give her a fun book.
AUDIENCE: So during
this trip, what
was the sausage that ended
up being your favorite--
that you couldn't stop?
CHRIS YING: In Germany.
So I've had a lot of
cheese sausages in my life,
and I always find them to
be pretty disappointing.
Because it's like, this
is a blue cheese sausage,
and you can't really tell--
doesn't mean anything.
It just means, like,
somebody ate some blue cheese
while they were making
your sausage, or whatever.
But in Germany-- I
think specifically,
we were in Munich.
And I think it's actually
an Austrian sausage called
the Kasekrainer, which
is a cheese sausage.
And we sliced into it,
and was sort of again
disappointed-- I was like,
oh, there's no cheese in here.
And then miraculously, sort of
out of these invisible pores,
all this melted cheese started
oozing out of the sausage.
And it was the most
incredible thing.
And I asked Eli Cairo
from Olympia Provisions
sort of about how it's made.
And it all has to do with
kind of the temperature,
and making sure you
are mixing this sausage
at a really cold temperature,
so the cheese doesn't distribute
into the meat.
But that was amazing.
I couldn't get enough of that.
It was the best cheese
sausage I'd ever had.
So, yeah.
I don't know.
Anybody else want a sticker?
Was a great question?
AUDIENCE: I want to know
about "Lucky Peach."
Are you planning on
taking over the world?
What's the next
step in domination?
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
So, I mean, "Lucky
Peach" started, honestly,
as this crazy little whim
that three of us had.
We thought we could
make a magazine
and just focus on the
things that we thought
were funny and interesting.
And it turned out that
a lot of other people
found the same things
interesting as we did.
Like I said, originally, we
were going to do "101 Easy Asian
Recipes" as a joke.
But once we found
this audience, it
was kind of like, now we
should do this for real.
So cookbooks-- we
went five years
without a proper website,
which I don't think
was smart in retrospect.
But we're rebuilding
our website.
Yeah, we're trying to grow it.
And in the way that we
try to make the magazine
this big lush object
that people want to save,
we kind of want to play to
the forms that we expand to.
So when we do digital
things, we hope
that we're not just online
for the sake of being online.
You know, we're not just
making a "Lucky Peach" app,
because everyone
else has an app.
So, yeah-- very slow domination
of a tiny corner of the world
is our plan.
You got questions?
BRANDON CHALK: Yeah.
Of course I have questions.
So you had mentioned that
"The Wurst of Lucky Peach"
is the first of a series of
single-subject cookbooks.
What other--
CHRIS YING: Oh my God.
This guy's the best.
Brandon's the best.
So our very next book is
called "All About Eggs."
And I think the
subtitle I came up
was like, "Everything We
Know about the World's Most
Important Food."
So it'll be eggs-- will be next.
And then after that,
it's kind of in the air.
I would love to do more books
in the way of those "Time Life"
books, where you sort of study
certain cuisines of the world.
My mom has been bothering me to
do a book about-- she's always
like, Chris, do a
book about coconut.
And I'm like, Mom, no one
gives a shit about coconut.
ARALYN BEAUMONT: But you're
realizing she's right.
CHRIS YING: I know, right?
ARALYN BEAUMONT: The
more you think about it--
BRANDON CHALK: Like,
coconut water--
I feel like that's
gotten really big
in the last couple of years.
CHRIS YING: Yeah,
coconut water and curry.
Everyone loves curry,
so-- stupid moms.
ARALYN BEAUMONT:
Coconut desserts.
CHRIS YING: Coconut desserts?
My god.
BRANDON CHALK: Coconut ketchup.
CHRIS YING: No coconut ketchup.
But yeah, that's sort
of next on the pipeline.
I don't know.
It's a fun thing, because
just like with sausages,
you think it's this very
specific, narrow topic.
And then you kind of realize
that having these constraints
lets you be more
creative in how you
approach a subject, how you come
up with things to talk about.
So yeah, I don't know-- I'm
looking forward to other books.
AUDIENCE: So you claimed
to not be a chef,
but what got you into this
food space in general?
Was it parents cooking,
or something else?
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
I personally grew up in a
little bit of a food family.
My mom owned a Mexican
restaurant and two ice cream
stores.
But I think a lot of
first generation--
am I first generation?
Whatever generation
of Asian person
I am-- I think a lot of us
sort of realized in the last 10
or 15 years-- the way we
grew up, the things we ate,
the familiar ways that
we ate with our families,
had some kind of value
or interest to people.
And when I got to
college, I sort of
started sharing some of the
things that I ate as a kid,
with my roommates and
friends and things like that.
And I cooked in a restaurant
for four or five years.
I helped open Mission Street
Food and Mission Chinese Food.
But I never really
wanted these two worlds
to come together--
the writing thing
I was doing at this
company called McSweeney's,
and the food stuff.
And then I met Dave
Chang and Peter Meehan,
and they kind of
convinced me to do this.
And now I'm here making
chorizo for people at Google.
And I just, like, I
don't know what happened.
At some point, everything
went off the rails,
and now I do this.
But yeah, no-- I mean, I
think that for me, it's
been a really long process
of-- or really, fortunate
process-- that me
discovering what food meant
to me as a person coincided
with everyone kind of starting
to care more about food
and paying attention
to how food plays into
our own American culture.
So yeah.
All right.
Any last questions?
Do you want a sticker?
Give the man a sticker.
All right.
Well, here we go.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
made weird sausage stuff?
Like the ones with
intestines inside?
CHRIS YING: Have I ever
made weird sausage stuff
with intestines inside?
AUDIENCE: Or whater.
CHRIS YING: I've not personally
made the crazy, crazy sausages,
that are like-- there are
sausages, like she said,
that are intestines stuffed with
more intestines and other organ
meats, and really just
made from the off-cuts
and things like that.
And andouillette is made
from the lower intestine,
and is kind of prized for how
poopy it smells and tastes.
I haven't made too much of that.
But I've been making sausage
since I was in college,
and really found
it to be rewarding,
once you have kind of a rough
formula for what goes in it.
You can just sort of
mess around and put
whatever you want in there.
So at Thanksgiving time,
I make a turkey sausage
with green Szechuan
peppercorn and all this, like,
funky-- it's really tingly,
and numbing, and spicy.
And that was just kind
of pulled out of nowhere.
So it's fun to just do whatever.
And that's in the book.
AUDIENCE: So out of all the
ones that you make at home
for your own personal
use, which one do you
find you making the most of?
CHRIS YING: I would
say, because I make it
on such a consistent basis,
that sort of weird Thanksgiving
turkey tingling sausage is
the one I make most regularly.
And I have this whole
break down system.
I describe it in the book,
too, where it's like,
one turkey breast goes
here, another one goes here,
and then the legs go this way.
So Thanksgiving
turkey at my house
is like a weird smorgasbord.
Other than that,
the loose sausages
are the easiest and
most approachable.
So you can make
them super often.
You're going to make this over
and over and over again now.
You know, you can make
breakfast sausage really easily.
Those are probably the
most approachable ones.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YING: Thanks, guys.